[Música]
hablamos de la salud con más romeros a
la mar bienvenida muy buen día
comenzamos con una agencia europea del
medicamento que aprobó las dosis de
refuerzo de la vacuna contra el hobbit
19 de moderna la verdad es que era una
decisión que se esperaba a raúl porque
hace nada lo hicieron también con la
vacuna de facer para mí la principal
noticia es que lo hacen las
recomendaciones para la población
general para todo el mundo mayor de 18
años recordemos es sólo una
recomendación luego todos los países
darán lo que lo que consideren
escuchemos como justificaron esta
decisión
la decisión sigue los datos que muestran
que una tercera dosis de speed bucks
dada entre 6 y 8 meses después de la
segunda dosis provoca un aumento de los
niveles de anticuerpos en adultos cuyas
defensas estaban menguando la dosis de
refuerzo consiste en la mitad de la
dosis usada para las primeras
vacunaciones
si te parece raúl lo podemos repasar un
poco en que van estas entidades
reguladoras porque a veces cada vez es
más un galimatías cada semana tenemos
noticias nuevas recordemos la agencia
europea del medicamento ha aprobado
dosis de refuerzo para la población en
general tanto de las vacunas de modernas
como de facer mientras que su
equivalente en eeuu la de cede a esas
vacunas sólo las ha aprobado para los
mayores de 65 años población en riesgo y
en cambio se ha aprobado para la
población general una segunda dosis de
la vacuna de johnson johnson es
importante que nos fijemos en cómo van
porque estas dos agencias son las que
están marcando un poco el camino de cómo
lucharemos contra la pandemia con estas
vacunas y todo esto mientras siguen las
dudas alrededor de si efectivamente son
necesarias estas dosis de refuerzo
efectivamente se muestran los datos que
tenemos que hay un aumento de los
niveles de anticuerpos especialmente en
la gente mayor que los ha ido perdiendo
después de meses de ser vacunados pero
la duda sobre todo es en si es necesario
en este momento de la pandemia
recordemos que las vacunas siguen
protegiendo según los datos que tenemos
contra el cubit grave contra las
hospitalizaciones contra las es que en
eeuu por ejemplo el 40 de la población
no está vacunada todavía entonces eso
debería ser prioritario que en europa
alrededor del 30% en la mayoría de
países tampoco está vacunada a la
población entonces quizás deberíamos
centrarnos en eso también recordando una
vez más que hay falta de disponibilidad
de vacunas en muchísimas otras partes
del mundo entonces bueno seguiremos los
pasos pero tenemos que siempre tener un
punto crítico así es marc pero seguimos
hablando de la pandemia echemos una
mirada hacia atrás el pasado en los
inicios porque tenemos nuevos datos
sobre cuando llegó el virus a europa y
también hasta los sonidos seguimos como
con origen si es un estudio que publicó
ayer la revista nation y que revisa ese
inicio de la pandemia y hasta cierto
punto revisar los datos que publican
pueden ser hasta un jarro de agua fría
no porque nos recuerda como cómo empezó
todo a inicios de 2020 escuchemos cuál
fue la principal conclusión del estudio
descubrimos que la transmisión
comunitaria de sars coptos probablemente
se dio en varias áreas de europa y de
eeuu en enero de 2020 y estimamos que a
inicios de marzo sólo una de cada tres
en 100 infecciones se detectaban en los
sistemas de vigilancia los resultados
destacan los viajes internacionales como
la clave en la introducción de sars cap
2 con posibles introducciones y eventos
de transmisión tan pronto como diciembre
de 2019 o enero de 2020 estos datos que
está dando la revista han hecho también
lo reflejaron en unos gráficos aquí les
hemos copiado de pronto el principal el
gráfico que sacan y vemos que el inicio
en europa el primer país que empezó con
las pandemias de este país de aquí
arriba de todo es italia y eso cuando en
europa en verdad se considera se
considera que el primer caso detectado
fue en francia el 24 de enero para esas
fechas según este modelo publicado por
la revista en ayer ya había transmisión
comunitaria tanto en francia como en
italia transmisión comunitaria se
considera que son 10 casos 10 contagios
de kobe 19 locales no importados en eeuu
pasa un poco lo mismo el primer caso que
se detectó fue el 21 de enero y también
considerar que ya dos días antes del 19
de enero ya había más de 10 personas
contagiadas de kobe en ese momento que
conclusiones extraemos de aquí también
para evitar un poco ese jarro de agua
fría no como que podemos extraer para
prepararnos mejor para el futuro primero
es que esa vigilancia sobre los primeros
casos se hizo sólo en individuos
sintomáticos que tenían historial de
viajes a china por ejemplo no habían
pruebas no se detectaron el 97 por
ciento de los casos de esas etapas
tempranas de la pandemia y eso pues nos
habla de que si esas restricciones si
hubiéramos tenido esos datos quizás las
restricciones hubieran podido
implementar antes y hubiéramos evitado
una explosión de casos como la
escribimos en países como españa o como
italia en cualquier caso sirve para
prepararnos para futuras pandemias que
espero que sigan siendo lejanas y vamos
a prepararnos para la gripe no creo que
ya tú y yo estamos haciendo de esta
gripe además en el invierno un poco de
ataque está fortísimo yo viendo todos
los días impresionante granizo que se
prevé para este año con respecto a la
gripe mar pues como tú bien decías se
acerca el invierno aquí en colombia es
un poco distinto pero en el hemisferio
norte eso significa la llegada de la
navidad pero también la llegada de la
gripe estacional y estamos un poco en
alerta porque venimos de dos años en los
que la transmisión de la gripe también
se ha restringido gracias a un poco a
las restricciones por la pandemia de
kobe 19 además entonces eso hace que
tengamos mucha menos inmunidad adquirida
y stm que esta gripe estacional en el
hemisferio norte puede hacer un poco más
virulenta pero bueno que podemos hacer
antes que eso podemos revisar qué pasa
qué pasó en el hemisferio sur que acaba
de salir
del invierno recogimos el caso de
argentina por ejemplo en el que sabemos
que los datos que tenemos es que bajaron
los casos de gripe significativamente
una un 30% prácticamente en eeuu en
cambio vemos que la muerte de caso el
perdón las muertes por casos de gripe
también descendió de manera abismal un
90 por ciento prácticamente recordemos
las fechas en argentina es en este año
2021 respecto a 2020 que ya era un año
pandémico eso nos da buenas buenas
señales un poco de que puede ser que
este año aunque se estén relajando las
restricciones en la mayor parte de
países sigamos viendo
una progresión a la baja de este tipo de
enfermedad también que más podemos hacer
pues estar preparados' vacunarnos
recordamos que la vacunación contra la
gripe sigue siendo una campaña actual en
la mayoría de países no hay ninguna
contraindicación sobre solapar la vacuna
de competición hablé con la de la gripe
entonces pues estar preparados consultar
siempre con un médico porque los
síntomas se parecen ya lo sabemos y
estar atentos a los diagnósticos y como
las abuelitas margen jibril limón y
pueden vitamina c y precaución mar
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud nos vemos mañana